well the Food and Drug Administration is
set to crack down on sales of flavored
East cigarette products claiming they
are highly addictive and have become
hugely popular with minors the FDA
confirms reports that say it could take
action as soon as next week Anna Werner
has been covering the e-cigarette story
for many months now and she is here with
new information Anna good morning good
morning and as we had told you before in
September the FDA had set a 60-day
deadline for several major east
cigarette companies to prove that they
could keep cigarettes away from kids one
in particular called Jul holds more than
70 percent of the e-cigarette market
share overall it has become
overwhelmingly popular with minors now
experts say that flavored products like
mango and fruit particularly appeal to
young people now Commissioner Scott
Gatlin plans to ban sales of most
flavored East cigarettes in two places
convenience stores and gas stations the
restriction would reportedly not a flaw
apply that is to mint flavors because
menthol cigarettes are sold
he's also considering online
restrictions including having age
verification requirements for those
sales
now advocacy groups looking to protect
teens told me last night that they're
pleased to see what they call first
steps from the FDA but they also point
out for example that since the move will
not affect mint flavor at least for now
they worry that kids may just switch
over to that we also reached out to Jul
about these possible new restrictions
the company did not offer a comment as
of last night but you know in the past
they have said that they never intended
for their product to be attractive to
teens and that they're very intent on
trying to stop its use among youth in
this country but their flavor choices
seem to indicate otherwise about who
they were marketing
well they say not they say they maintain
that some adults really do like flavors
right that it's not just something for
youth but anti tobacco experts see it
completely differently they say flavors
appeal to kids stop yeah so two sides of
the coin there and I thank you